Should someone always be detached?
Okay. Straightforward question.
The answer is no.
Someone shouldn't always be detached
cause otherwise you aren't enjoying
anything in your life. So
don't always be attached,
detached. No. But at the
same time, that being said,
you should be aware all the time if you
are getting sucked into the emotional
vortex, right? You've got to be aware
of that. Once you have that awareness,
you don't need to be attached all
the time at all. Yeah, you can.
I'm not always detached at all,
but,
but I've got clear warning signs when
things start going sideways and I started
going down some vortex, I know immediately
and I just attach. So it's really easy.
It's,
but it's,
it does take practice and eventually
you realize that you know when you're
feeling overwhelmed,
when you're feeling emotional and
you're feeling angry or you're feeling
frustrated,
when you start feeling those things and
you've sent them really quickly and you
recognize them, you just
attach, boom, you're done.
So that's what you've got to do.
Start recognizing those red flags so
that you can enjoy the good things.
And when something starts getting
crazy, you can detach. Yes.
So it's like an overall skill of being
able to control when to detach and when
you don't have to.
Being able to identify
when you need to detach,
then being able to
detach then you're good.
So it's like it's a matter of being
capable of making an accurate,
beneficial choice. Yes.
But the identification is
the hard part. Yes. People,
what happens to people when they talk
to me is they go the after the fact,
they realize I lost my temper
and I did this. Yeah. Okay.
You didn't detach it in time and
that's why you ended up there. Yeah.
So or I said some things to my,
you know,
my ex girlfriend that I shouldn't have
said cause I got to emotional. Exactly.
You didn't attach in time.
You got crazy and emotional.
So the skill that you're
missing is identifying when
you're starting to get too
emotional, whatever that emotion might
be. Once you identify it, boom, detach,
take control, then you can take
control. Yes. And make tactical moves,
not emotional moves. That's ultimately
the art, you know, to make the move.
You know how like did you two guys,
if they never actually know,
you know what the moves,
when you're emotionally detached,
the moves actually aren't that hard.
They're actually usually pretty obvious.
Like you're, you're in a fight
with your girlfriend and,
and you're starting to go down the wrong
lane. As soon as you detach, you go, oh,
I know what I need to do.
I should say I'm sorry and tell her that
we can go to the restaurant that she
wants to go to or whatever.
You know what I mean? The,
the movers are not actually that hard,
but we never make good moves when we're
being emotional. Instead we just go, no,
I don't want to go to that restaurant.
We went there three weeks to go,
I don't care if I said that to you. You
deserve me to say that to you. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. That, that's a, you
go down the wrong path.
But what if like detached the whole time,
even when problems don't arise,
you know, like then we don't have a
relationship. Right. That's what I mean.
That's a problem. That's what I'm
saying. [inaudible] all the time.
That's what I'm, that's the
answer to the question. Right?
So it's like you've reiterated
it for everyone. Yeah, man.
That's what I'm here for.
I think a lot of times you don't
have guys will ask you, Hey,
I want to learn Jujitsu. I want to
learn to mess people up. It's like, Bro,
that's not really what it is.
Did you get to,
is having the skills to
quote unquote mess people up?
But what you learn ultimately is you
put yourself in a position where you can
make that decision. Is it time to
mess someone up or not? You know?
And you just have to
control the situation.
So that's really what most people
that start with the vision. No,
I want to build a mess people up.
Most people continued that,
that do continue on the journey of what
you did to arrive at a point where they
realize that they don't want to abuse this
power that they now have. Most people,
yeah, there's a small percentage of
people that don't, that are bullies.
They were bullies when they started and
they become more effective. Bullies. Yeah.
More fearful,
more more fear in posing bullies,
which sucks. But you did see his power.
That's why you got to have some of it.
Yeah. Agree. But compare it to like a,
I dunno anything where it's like striking
based or whatever. It's like you,
it like I've said this for,
I'm not gonna go deep in it,
but you go from zero to 10 when you throw
a strike that's you're already at 10
you know, you can't just throw a light
one and be like, okay, are we cool now?
You know, kind of thing goes, not cool.
Nope. You slapped me in the face man.
Cool it all you brought it to 10
when he knocked him out or not.
So because like I see,
I see my kids and what you're talking
about can happen very easily when other
people are in the group with my kids. I
mean, yeah cause they'd been training.
Did you get too,
so even like against any
normal kid there is no factor.
Yeah. Like I see me and my
son will be wrestling around
with some kids. No factor.
Yeah. And it's, you know, it's kind
of cool. Yeah. Cool. It's real cool.
Yeah. You know, my kids
aren't like Jujitsu,
like there's kids out there that are sick,
competitive, Jujitsu all the time. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. That's not
what I'm talking about.
Like just knowing Jujitsu a
hundred percent correct. Yes. And,
but when I see kids doing Jujitsu,
especially like,
I'm not saying in the necessarily,
even in a tournament,
I'm just saying in Jujitsu, in
class, even at the beach or whatever,
when I see them, I'm like, man,
I wish I could have done
Jujitsu when I was a little kid.
You don't find that it'd be, yeah,
man. Yeah. Make up for it now. Try it.